to Ukraine now where United Nations
nuclear experts have left the capital
key for the occupied power plant near
separation the team will assess the
condition of the facility and any danger
nearby fighting could pose for Europe's
largest nuclear power station lead
investigator Rafael crossy told
journalists the U.N experts hoped to
help stabilize the situation
the plant has been occupied by Russian
troops since March and has repeatedly
been shelled both Moscow and Kiev blame
each other for the attacks
DW correspondent Martinez Bollinger is
in zabaricia I asked him what the U.N
inspectors will focus on during their
visit
the way now they will possibly arrive
tonight or tomorrow morning on the site
and they will be looking for
um uh Damage Done to the facility there
has been shelling in in Eldar for now
some weeks that some of it has hit
closely to the plant or to electric
lines and other important structures
near the plant so they will assess the
damage that's the first thing they will
assess how the security systems are
working every power plant has a range of
systems that are either need to be
activated in cases of security or that
protect the uh the power plant and that
will ensure that cooling keeps on so
there cannot be no a nuclear meltdown so
this is the second thing they want to do
and the third thing is that they want to
talk to the staff the Ukrainian stuff in
this power plant and see what their
working conditions are like in and
whether this is still sustainable
so Matthias has been speaking to people
fleeing the Russian occupied area around
the nuclear power plant one of them was
a technical worker from the facility he
says he's concerned about its safety and
fears Russia may try to conceal the
reality of the situation from the U.N
inspectors
some have spent hours some days waiting
for this moment here in zaporizia
refugees arrive from the occupied
territories in the south
some are fleeing the fighting some life
and occupation and recently new worries
have emerged
we live about 40 kilometers
officially we're not in the danger zone
but it's not far
[Music]
when they shoot we can hear it
so we decided to pack our things and
leave
the refugees are registered and get food
and assistance
buses are waiting for those who want to
travel on
the past few days many have arrived from
the embattled city of inner hodar
we have spoken to a few people who have
just left an erdar and the nuclear power
station there they're talking about
constant shelling they're saying they
are afraid of what might happen to the
nuclear power station and that they want
to move as far as possible from there
none of them agreed to speak on camera
out of concern for relatives they've
left behind
but we managed to reach aliacorapetz by
video call he passed through here a few
days ago he was an engineer at the plant
and was on shifts until last week he
thinks the risk at the plant grows as
more colleagues leave
the station needs constant maintenance
now this work is not being done
at a power plant everything should go
like clockwork from the beginning of a
maintenance job until the end there
should be a strict schedule everything
needs to be done at certain hours
certain days on certain shifts now the
clock is broken it's still ticking but
it doesn't work anymore
he doesn't believe the mission of the
international atomic energy Authority
will have any impact
he doubts they will get the full picture
based on the visit of a Russian TV crew
to the plant
s
they showed the crew that they were
removing military equipment from the
plant and that everything was working
well
just after the journalists left they
brought everything back in
they have learned how to make propaganda
they know how to prepare pictures
when the iaea comes they will show them
a nice picture
when the iaea leaves
everything will be the same as before
those who have made it out are relieved
nobody knows for how long the roads will
be open